hello and welcome to uh microsoft
research summit 2021 uh this is our talk
on the state and future of software
supply chain security my name is adrian
diglio and i'm joined here with my
colleague michael scoveta first we're
going to start out with a quick
disclaimer this talk and accompanying
slides are for general information
purposes only and are not intended to
constitute legal and professional advice
a little bit about myself
i'm adrian diglio i'm
a program manager inside microsoft that
is leading the central strategy to
secure our software supply chain
i've been at uh panelist discussions
before with other industry peers uh both
with us department of energy and with
north carolina state university
um i've got my bachelorette from
cal poly and my master's from sdsu
and and some industry certifications and
i'm mike scaveda i'm a principal at
microsoft i lead an open source security
team our goal is to make sure that
microsoft is protected from vulnerable
or dangerous uh open source software i
also lead a work group within the open
source security foundation
and i have a master's from cornell in in
computer science and um
and assist
and so in our talk today we're going to
cover two topics
first mike is going to talk about what
software supply chains are and why we
need to help secure them and then i'll
come back and talk about how microsoft
thinks about this problem and our
approach for managing the risks over to
you mike thanks adrian
so modern software is practically never
built in isolation we all stand on the
shoulder of giants with those giants
being other software components
libraries services hardware
um that that we use to help deliver
products that delight our customers
a software supply chain is really this
collection and the interaction of
everything that goes into delivering
your product uh your your software
product or your service it includes
things like third-party vendors like the
software that you get from microsoft
the uh external service providers
whether it's a cloud service provider
like microsoft or amazon or google uh
source code repositories like github
and everything else that that that you
that you don't have to write yourself
that you leverage um someone else's work
but it also includes things like the
laptops and the other hardware that your
that your developers use and how they
how they interact with
uh with systems that they're building it
includes the distribution channel to
customers how you actually get your
service in front of the users including
things that you wouldn't normally think
about like their internet service
providers the software supply chain has
been around for as long as software has
but in the past 15 or 20 years there's
been a seismic shift
one of the reasons for this shift is a
very large and increasing reliance on
open source software in fact the average
software application now depends on over
500 different open source libraries
according to a report from sonotype
there's increase in complexity but many
times these these
open source components depend on yet
other open source components
there's more parties involved so
if you if you are one of these
applications that have 500 different um
open source dependencies these are at
least hundreds of different um
people that have that are contributing
to your service that you've never met
that you have no relationship with
there are also inherent adversary
advantages when an attacker tries to
compromise a software supply chain they
can
especially when it's around open source
they can do this in isolation and
analyze for days or weeks before before
mounting an attack and when they do
attack
the payoff is higher
the average ransomware attack is close
to six hundred thousand dollars um from
uh from another recent report so this
has been in the news it's been in the
news for years
i think what's changed in the past few
have been
that attackers are now targeting
critical systems so two recent
[Music]
breaches were or attempted breaches one
was the attempted attack on the florida
uh florida's water system
uh and the other was the the successful
colonial pipeline breach these had
particularly the colonial pipeline which
had a massive impact
solar winds is another good example
um
solar winds was is interesting because
it didn't target traditional
um it didn't have a traditional target
at targeted build systems
this has all kind of culminated in the
realization that software supply chain
is critically important to organizations
and and countries uh so we see some
movement happening uh federally at the
with the recent executive orders on
on improving
supply chains and lots of other
legislation and and things that are
coming to to to make sure that uh
organizations uh mitigate this risk
sufficiently
so let's think about open source
software development in particular and
in a lot of ways this mirrors
any other software development but
consider you know if you take
a
an open source project that someone
built and maintained you can kind of
bucketize
the risk into in a couple different
categories one is the risks that take
place locally when they're writing their
code on their own laptop and then when
they're done they publish this to a
package repository and they make it
available for the world to use
and then you being an organization that
that's using this this package downloads
it
and then you use it in your application
you ship it into service or you know put
it on a
on a download or anything like that and
at each of these areas there's there are
threats and and risks that can come in
to compromise
the supply chain and remember you only
really need
one compromise of any of these things
um
can can impact the final service that
you're delivering to your to your users
so
attacks against
in these areas have been you know
prevalent for years um a few recent ones
though so so co-maintainer is attacker
it's kind of the the way the way that we
describe
um cases where
you as a maintainer of an open source
component you know you're you're busy
someone comes along and says hey can i
help you out i'd love to partner with
you and maintain this
uh this happened in 2018 when the uh
there was a the event stream uh npm
project uh was compromised this way
within with an attacker coming in and
asking to help the maintainer gave them
access and the maintainer quickly added
a malicious sub dependency to that
package and
chaos kind of ensued compromise
credentials happen all the time
met and in many cases uh
there's particularly prevalent package
managers where you could publish
something to npm or to
pi pi or nuget or another another
package ecosystem
and
you lose those credentials uh you lose a
publishing token or something like that
an attacker finds it and and publishes a
new version of the package
that has malware or something else kind
of
evil in it
and i haven't even talked about regular
vulnerabilities but regular
vulnerabilities are everywhere because
humans write software and
humans make mistakes and some of those
mistakes are security vulnerabilities
but the problem here isn't so much this
this single
thread of
um of threats but it's the way that
these things kind of stitch together
because remember open source depends on
other open source and your software
depends on
third parties the entire your your
entire graph of of dependencies can
can impact
the final
your final service so imagine
that we just zoom in on here and let's
take this one in the middle the
compromise tool chain
so the example the the the scenario here
is you use a compiler and a some sort of
a build tool to to create your um to
create your package
well that
that tool chain is software too
so that was delivered to you at the end
of someone else's
um
flow here that i'm describing and even
there that software was written on
hardware that
has software running on it which was
written by yet other people
so it almost seems kind of fractal in
nature where you can you can zoom in
really really far and you realize that
the simple
web application that you're that that
you're developing
it doesn't depend on dozens it depends
on thousands
of people
that are all that are all making
mistakes sometimes and and all um
can be compromised to deliver your your
final thing
so
while the attack surface is enormous and
it's enough to keep a lot of people uh
like me up at night
you still need to ship software
you can't just be paralyzed um by this
by this risk
um
you have to ship something
and
for that i'm going to leave this to
adrian to talk to you about
microsoft's approach here thank you
michael now that we have that context i
want us to begin dissecting the problem
into various segments and start to
review microsoft's solution approach
we'll try to tackle the full breadth of
the problem highlighting hard technical
problems as we go and we'll start
digging in
at microsoft we have a complex
heterogeneous environment we have over a
hundred thousand developers
so as we approach this problem
i'm gonna i'm gonna use some basic
examples such as azure devops
azure devops is a
is a well-known devops ci cd platform
and
there is such a large attack surface
when you look at all the touch points
across the cicd infrastructure
some threats here can be performed by
external attackers
such as malicious oss packages and
plug-ins
but most threats represented on this
slide are actions that can be performed
by an adversary that has already gained
initial access to the engineering system
this is why the assume breach mindset is
so important when developing solutions
to this space
when we look at across the landscape
today lower sophistication attacks such
as code cove dependency confusion and
type of squatting are
much more frequent and more successful
these attacks uh techniques target
developers dependencies that get pulled
into a build environment such as open
source software build tools compilers
linkers and sdks
usually when the objective
of the attacker is to compromise the
developers workstation or exfiltrate
build environment credentials to an
attacker controlled server this would
grant the attacker initial access to our
engineering systems which is in that
compromise workflow down below
depicting the cyber attack chain and
once they have this initial access to
our engineering systems that's when they
start to pivot and escalate permissions
within the environment until they can
act on their ultimate objective which is
in the post-compromise phase depicted
below
and that acting on objective potentially
is where they're targeting our build
machines or searching for secrets in
source to then go compromise our
production services there is also a
potential threat that any of these lower
sophistication attacks
could execute ransomware in our
environment uh halting microsoft's
ability to develop software
when we look at these high
sophistication attacks
uh solarwinds in 2020 asus live update
in 2019 and see cleaner in 2017
uh they show how devastating a supply
chain attack can be for a company's
reputation and customer base
the above attacks were performed by
highly sophisticated adversaries that
all targeted the build machine
with the objective of compromising the
software produced to use the company's
software as a vehicle to distribute
their back door or malware and it abuses
the trust that these companies have
established with their respective
customers to ensure that the malicious
payload gets executed
if our products were successfully
compromised in this way it would result
in
immediate and possibly irrevocable loss
of our reputation and that's why
microsoft is so committed and focused on
this problem
so
defining the problem where does it begin
and end uh
michael already
talked took you through uh some of these
thoughts but you know it kind of begins
that first moment that a developer
starts writing code they choose which
ide that they want to develop in which
os is it running on top of and all the
software that gets brought into that
developer machine
and ultimately into the project that's
being developed
i would like to say that the supply
chain
ends
when a piece of software is successfully
and securely delivered
to the customer
but
if an attacker exploits a vulnerability
that you inherited from a piece of oss
that you took a dependency on
isn't that still attacking your supply
chain so
delivering it to the customer is not
necessarily the end it's kind of a ever
going evolution
of continuously protecting your supply
chain and securing the supply chain kind
of goes beyond
secure development life cycle practices
and goes beyond devsecops practices
though practices from both of those
disciplines uh often overlap and and and
do provide benefits toward securing your
supply chain but there is more that
needs to be done
um something when you look at this
system this is just a generic picture of
the evolution of a of software going
through modern day ci cd
uh something new that you might be
noticing here is that evidence store
depicted on the bottom more on that
later so our strategy
is uh
to segment this into bite-sized chunks
we are taking a threat based approach
focusing on reducing risk at each one of
these segments of our supply chain
because we need to be able to validate
our software development process and
validate that our build output is free
of anomalous or listed activity these
seven sections that i have here are
build environment
oss supply chain build tool supply chain
securing the devops platform itself
securing the developer workstation
environment
uh talking about how we can secure the
upstream meaning all of the things that
we consume from
and ultimately s bombs and supply chain
integrity evidence
as i progress through you will see
depictions in the bottom right hand
corner of the slide as well as numbers
in the in the top of the slide so that
you know which which part of which
segment we're referring to so
to me
because these highly sophisticated
attackers are our largest threat in
securing the supply chain focusing on
building machines is critical
microsoft's build machines should have
secure boot capabilities to protect them
from firmware root kits boot kits kernel
root kits and driver root kits
all the major supply chain attacks solar
winds asus live update ccleaner they
were all done by very sophisticated
adversaries that all targeted the build
machine
compromising the boot process in order
to get access to the build machine is
something that these adversaries could
do
are very capable of doing and i want to
be able to block that attack factor
entirely to protect our software supply
chain furthermore on on all the
different things that we can do to
secure the build environment itself
google released salsa which is a
maturity model for supply chain security
shown here are just the build related
items out of out of all the others
as you can see in salsa level 3 they
recommend ephemeral ephemeral build
environments where the build machine is
there to perform its task and then it's
it's blown away when you're when you're
done using it so that attackers have no
opportunity to maintain persistence in
your environment and also in level three
they talk about network isolation
because there should be no reason to
have access to the public internet
during a build this is how attackers
often call back to the command and
control servers to download a payload
or in the case of
ingesting compromised scripts that might
exfiltrate your secrets to a remote
server
if you've got network isolation in place
in your build environment those scripts
will run but they won't actually exfol
anything
at microsoft uh we're going a bit beyond
salsa
you know one example is security
monitoring of the build environment and
and looking at activity that's happening
there another example is applying code
integrity policies to the build
environment so that only signed trusted
binaries are allowed to execute in a
build environment which would have
prevented the ccleaner attack because
uh in that specific scenario they they
loaded a compromised dll into the
environment owasp also has the software
component verification standard which is
much more granular in terms of
requirements for its maturity model and
it's another great guide post here that
anybody can adopt and then
after a build once we produce the output
how do we go back
and and efficiently walk backwards to
the original artifacts that created and
make sure that what we produce is what
we expected to produce uh this is
essentially
asking the question how can we
reproducibly validate and this is hard
for a number of reasons uh
many languages have you know
non-deterministic builds um there are
date time stamp issues uh that are
happening in certain build environments
even minor changes in build tools could
have significant changes on the build
output like compiler flags uh so on and
so forth and you know sometimes source
information is lost in between stages we
have here a a few solutions uh that
we're pursuing um
reducing the amount of non-determinism
during our builds
um emphasizing declarative ephemeral
build environments
um so on and so forth participating in
reproduciblebuilds.org
where we can there are lots of
opportunities for improvements in this
space moving on to the oss supply chain
bucket the program that we have running
inside microsoft is is essentially a set
of eight practices we want to make sure
that you're ingesting and saving a local
copy of the artifact that you're
inventorying that auto that artifact
that you are scanning for
vulnerabilities and malware
that you are updating in a very timely
fashion uh we measure uh mean time to
remediate
uh and we you know try to use
technologies like uh dependebot to help
automate uh patching we also have a
audit
uh verifying the provenance and
integrity of those artifacts as we
consume them through the chain
and we also want to be able to
ultimately
enforce these policies on on enforcing
secure consumption because if if people
are able to pull
things from from any location anywhere
it's possible that they can they can
mess up uh or or accidentally pull in
something that they they didn't intend
and and so uh establishing a uh
ingestion gates that evaluate these
packages upon consumption
uh to block the bad and and let through
the good um is
is a big part of securing our supply
chain
um additionally being able to rebuild
from source uh where it makes sense so
that uh in extreme situations if you
uncover um a a critical vulnerability
you can be able to implement a private
fix
rebuild it and distribute it
while you
partner with the upstream maintainer and
wait for them to make the fix and so you
can't
do all eight practices right from the
get-go
uh you need to do them in phases
and this is where i get to the maturity
model
and you can walk through this uh level
one you know basic ingestion inventory
scanning for known vulnerabilities and
manual updating
moving to secure ingestion to protect
you from dependency confusion
scanning for malware automatic oss
updates like uh with technology like
dependabot
and moving over to level three where
you're actually
cloning the oss source locally so that
you can perform proactive security
reviews and look for those
uh back doors and other unknown
vulnerabilities uh and being able to
contribute your findings back to the
upstream maintainer
and ultimately uh level four this is
where a lot of uh there's a lot of
subtle hard technical problems uh when
it comes to rebuilding and implementing
private fixes
rebuilding is actually tougher than
sounds due to non-determinism
and the reason why
we would be motivated to rebuild oss is
because it's often done in a black box
developers can build on their local
desktops they can introduce new scripts
or dependencies that aren't found in
their repo or they could be building in
a compromised environment so while
reproducibly rebuilding is a little bit
out of reach for some languages like
javascript we have published a new git
that does help you
establish settings to support
reproducibility
for nuget packages but organizations
that want to rebuild oss on trusted
infrastructure
this is a hard problem
you could produce
a functionally equivalent rebuild
but it won't be a bit for bit hash match
also when you start thinking about
private fixes this is also very
tricky because
if you implement a private fix do you do
you rev the version number with semantic
versioning well you can't really do that
because the upstream maintainer is going
to rev their version number and you
don't want to conflict so then do you
rename the package and then how do you
make sure that all of your developers
across your organization get this
renamed package so these are all the
subtle hard problems that we are are
tackling now and so with software build
dependencies
uh this is the the third step of pulling
in you know build tools and sdks things
that could be coming from all over the
internet this is really an exercise in
reducing our attackable surface and
removing our reliance on the public
internet so we want to host an internal
store where we can start pulling down
these binaries and hosting them in a
secure location where they can be vetted
and reviewed and approved for use and
then all developers can start pulling
from this internal storage location
rather than constantly calling and
making outbound calls this is
uh something that we're we're piloting
we are working on adapting
a version of the relative attack surface
quotient which was
initially created to measure the attack
surface of an operating system
we're looking to adapt that formula and
apply it to a build environment so that
we can calculate
the total attackable surface
uh
prior to implementing these things and
then measuring it as it goes down over
time as as
we gain adoption in these new tools and
and standard best practices
devops platform security this is uh
getting back to you know using azure
devops as as an example you know
identity uh for for years now has become
the new perimeter protecting credentials
is paramount to protecting your castle
this is why mfa is a must in this day
and age
additionally we found that attackers
that do gain that initial access they
still comb through repos looking for
hard-coded secrets so they can pivot and
compromise
a production service this is why i
highly recommend having no hard coded
seagates in your code and the easier
that we can make this for developers
uh the better thus
under this assume breach mindset
uh we need to establish secure baselines
of all the configurations that that our
builds are are taking for our code bases
and our pipelines
we should have two-person uh review on
all the changes to as a mitigation
against malicious edits because if a
person is in there and they want to add
their little malicious build step
we need to make sure that we have humans
monitoring that
um as a as a first step in mitigating
this
uh anything that requires admin level
permissions we need just-in-time
elevation of permissions to to do that
so that we have no account with
persistent admin permissions
and we also want to encourage teams that
to take that threat model concept which
is traditionally done looking at the
production service
um and and
re-think that and have the the threat
model done on the build environment
itself so that you understand all of the
inputs that are going into the build and
it forces development teams to think
about it in a new way
developer workstation security is
another important it's it's kind of like
the first line of defense in many ways
because developer workstations are
usually also connected to the internet
and they receive email one wrong click
and the developer's credentials are
compromised this would grant an attacker
access to anything that's been pulled to
this local desktop and as you can
imagine
a lot of developers will do a clone
of the source code from this highly
secure
you know
version control system and pull it down
to their desktop so it's going from like
one security boundary into another which
is considered a little bit less secure
and
you know that clone source is
intellectual property and it's now low
hanging fruit so if an attacker does
compromise that credential they can
easily get
what's locally there and
they can easily exfil that code and
potentially sell it for ransom and we've
seen that a couple times in the news and
so
for the next thing uh mike i want you to
tell us about how we can all be a better
member of the security community thanks
adrian
uh so
we all depend on open source extensively
i think that's just just a reality of
modern development you know our goal in
this kind of part of the process is to
have some sort of assurance that the
open source
and third party um software that we
depend on actually is free from
vulnerabilities so this is different
than being
free from known cves or having you know
integrity validated from point a to
point b or things like this this is
actually you know opening up the code
and looking at it and saying are there
vulnerabilities here that aren't public
are there back doors how has malware
been inserted and how do we do this at
scale
um relative to the number of projects
that are in use so microsoft is while we
are a large organization um
this is this is not a microsoft problem
this is a problem for the entire world
so to help address this uh we helped to
create the open source security
foundation uh which is a industry
organization you know designed to
kind of address this problem at scale
with for the entire open source
ecosystem there are a number of
different work groups uh involved in
this and we're all targeting different
areas and trying to improve things if
you're interested in this we welcome
participation from from you know
industry and organizations and anybody
who who
cares about this and and wants to help
them make the world a better place
back to you adrian and so here this is
the evidence store that i alluded to a
while back
skim supply chain integrity model is our
open specification on how to capture
policy such as rego from opa and
evidence that proves that you've
complied with the policy in a single
immutable
non-repudiable supply chain integrity
ledger skim becomes
the evidence store that enables software
to prove that it meets
say salsa level 2 as an example
and s-bombs come into the picture
because of their unique software
identifier that they contain
s-bombs contain much more information
and you know serve software integrity
and software transparency benefits as
well
but they also cater to pro
serving as the software identifier
this is poised to even potentially
replace
cpes which is how vulnerabilities are
mapped to to a software today
and so the software id could be used as
the lookup key in a skim evidence store
to validate that any supply chain
integrity evidence about the software
and so
what does success look like in the
future
our vision is that
in software supply chain security we
must be able to convey trust in
microsoft software and its supply chain
dependencies to our customers which is a
tall order
this is going to be accomplished through
building our software in a verifiable
trusted build environment using a
verifiable trusted chain of oss and
build tool dependencies each also built
in a verifiable trusted build
environment and recording this evidence
as proof
for anyone to validate in an immutable
non-reputable evidence store so thank
you for your time and attention today